tiana une cure dent du string et bah
tiens voilà alors oui non mais c'est
quand même hyper important les sous
vêtements chez un homme
ouais c'est quand même faut faire un
effort à ce niveau là je trouve et
d'avoir des choses assez basique comme
les chaussettes par exemple moi je crois
en moi je propose que tout le monde
montre son caleçon et voilà c'est la fin
des missions alesi à tout moment ce cas
c'est bon alors qu'au match aller
je vous dirais que je monte je
recommande j'ai pas trop le mot flynn de
coton blanc pas mal bah voilà mais bon
je pense que raymond va rigoler non vous
ne rêvez pas
jean miche pas possible chez toi tu as
dit que c'était bien ces bandes
dessinées squash pas possible mais ces
séries la mission médias vous avez voler
une canette au minibar
[Rires]